thank you all for coming I'm so thrilled
that you came to our first
of the year I am so thrilled that we've
been working with Ramon for the past
couple months I'm putting this together
he's a brilliant scholar a brilliant
mind and you'll hear so much of his
incredible wealth of information in this
talk all of you who did the workshop you
already saw all the amazing things he
pulled together primary sources and
headlines in that great map and you all
piece that map together on your own and
also with your fabulous facilitators can
we give your facilitators a little we
even had some of our students step in
and take the reins that was wonderful so
without further ado I present to you mr.
Abdul Rehman Malik and his talk from
Damascus to Duncan Coffee change oh good
good morning everyone thank you so much
for being here this morning with all the
considerations right in the middle of
the workshop my wife texted and said
that the power had gone out where we
live
up and up in Westville so there you go
there's exciting things waiting for us
when we get home and they will all be
made better by coffee when I think back
on my own personal relationship with
coffee and had I grown up here in the
United States I probably associated with
this Dunkin Donuts is the most
ubiquitous coffee brand in America I
have been to the most unusual little
places and old Dunkin Donuts pops up and
there's an absolute commitment that the
American people have to this brand even
though the coffee is mediocre and the
donuts will eventually kill you but I
did not grow up in the United States I
grew up in Canada and my and my earliest
memories of coffee Oh No
there there good lord
ah this is what I remember as my
earliest memories of earliest memories
of coffee and I'll tell you why I grew
up outside of the City of Toronto
Canada's most multicultural in fact one
of the most diverse cities on the planet
Earth my family is originally from the
subcontinent my father was born in
Punjab before the partition of India and
to India and Pakistan my mother was born
in Pakistan but both of our families
were from India to Pakistan on the
creation of the country in 1947 my
family is at Jaya family is a tea family
we are the kind of family that has tea
breakfast tea lunch tea afternoon tea
dinner and if the tea is not brewing
whilst the dinner is being finished my
father will still to this day glare over
at the kitchen and say I don't hear the
water boiling at which point the answer
you should give it's because Dad the tea
is already brewing and if that's not the
answer he's like what's going on to this
day I'll go back I'm 43 years old I'll
go back home to Toronto and my parents
home 2 3 in the morning I'm hearing the
kettle go off I'm hearing the rustle of
feet
my parents are downstairs making chai
chai tea was all about the home brewing
for one another brewing for each other
sharing the experience of tea together
it was a comfort coffee on the other
hand was special we had coffee as a
family once a week on Sundays we would
go to the mosque which was in the city
and we'd have Sunday school we'd attend
some talks and we'd have the youth group
and on the way home my mom and dad would
always stop at the corner of highway 427
and Dundas at the Mister Donut and my
earliest memories of coffee are at being
special we'd walk into the Mister Donut
I'd smell that incredible brew and you
know that smell we just need to say it
we all know it it's a thing that we
smell in the morning
our homes it's the thing that keeps us
coming back to Dunkin Donuts it's that
smell of brewed coffee a little bit of
bitterness and sweetness and those
lovely fresh doughnuts and we would sit
down and you know that was the time we'd
sit around and we'd sort of just talk
and it wasn't about family staff who's
mostly about the world and I felt very
grown-up that my parents were buying me
coffee
to this day my parents will go out for
coffee
we rarely brew coffee at home I do now
and they're happy about it but they
would never brew it themselves coffee
for them was a deeply social beverage
now like many of you I would have always
thought that coffee came from Colombia
in fact in a recent survey in the United
States when people were asked where does
coffee come from what master Dre said
Colombia Juan Valdez has done a very
good job and Juan Valdez is the creation
of a big corporation that wants to sort
of market coffee in a particular way but
then I remember I think it was in high
school or early university I found a
little article somewhere it might have
been at the mosque it might have been in
our own family's bookshelves which was
the article was entitled coffee the wine
of Islam now we were fairly observed to
be observant Muslim family we didn't
drink and so I this caught my eye the
wine of Islam I said this must be some
special kind of coffee so I started
reading this article and it was a
strange article because it had stories
about fought was and beheadings of
intrigue and espionage of people laying
siege to cities of colonizers stealing
coffee plants and of mystics who not
only brewed coffee but used it in secret
spiritual ceremonies so you know being a
bit of a cynic and knowing that my
co-religionists can sometime exaggerate
I was kind of like I don't know about
this I don't see any references I kind
of stuck it in the back of my head and I
forgot about it
fast forward to the mid 1990s and the
first Starbucks opened in Toronto I was
one of those eager people who went and
lined up to get my you know my
it was called the New Guinea Peaberry
some of you old-time Starbucks drinkers
will know the New Caney Peaberry was a
big deal wasn't it and they wouldn't put
they wouldn't make it every day but if
you ask them nicely
they'd brew one just for you and so I
would go and say here's the New Guinea P
berry and we'd have it and all of a
sudden this world of coffee started to
open up it was like wow coffee comes
from Indonesia and coffee comes from
Ethiopia and coffee comes from from from
Kenya maybe there was something going on
with that article that I had read and so
I started I started even more delving
into it getting into it and then one of
my own sort of spiritual teachers who
himself follows a mystical or Sufi path
he one day I was speaking about my love
for coffee
and he kind of said to me he goes you
know where I'm from we have special
prayers that we say before drinking
coffee I'm like say what he goes he goes
no we write prayers they said they're
short prayers and there's long prison
like I'm like che how long are the long
prayers he says they can run four or
five pages I said doesn't the coffee get
cold he says we make it very hot but he
said here's a nice short one and he
introduced me to this which is known as
the fatiha al-saleem it's the short fat
they are the short opening prayer that
one reads before imbibing coffee and
it's a magnificent prayer and so you
begin by reciting the opening chapter of
the Quran which is a common prayer
amongst amongst people of Muslim faith
but particularly in the in what we would
call the Middle East and it says that
you you make this prayer for the
scholars of the kawah Albania the brown
coffee the brown elixir right and the
family of the Prophet and it goes on to
praise the men and women of spirituality
and those who made it and then it asks
of God please relieve me of my debt
please give me goodness in this life in
the next life and
you finish off and you recite the prayer
and then you imbibe the coffee I was
hooked my teacher was from the Yemen and
I had to go further I had to go back to
those articles and once I started going
down that rabbit hole I realized myself
that I almost believed that my love for
coffee was sort of destined I was
destined to meet this lover and all my
life I'd been playing games and now I
understood because I knew that coffee
did something to me in the 1580s a a
great scholar and the preeminent scholar
in the Arabic language of coffee Abdul
Kadir al Jazeera who was from Al Jazeera
tell Arab which is the Arabian Peninsula
wrote a book on coffee it's 67 folios
and it's preserved in the bibliothèque
nationale in Paris in that he quotes
another scholar even Abdul Ghaffar who's
considered one of the earliest scholars
of coffee and he described coffee in
this beautiful way he said there's a
word that we have for coffee and it's
called Merck aha marek AHA is called
and it's half so it's almost comes from
inside of you like a like a breath mark
aha and what is mark aha mark aha is the
feeling of sprightliness of spirit
mental well-being and all together
wholeness that you get from a good cup
of coffee
I have barista friends who've never
heard of this word but they know what it
is because a good barista knows what a
god shot is ever heard this term God
shot a good barista will say I'm looking
for the God shot and the God shot is
that cup of espresso so perfectly
engineered time to perfection dosed at
the right level with the perfect water
that when you have it it's like oh yeah
disappear you take it in and the flavors
overwhelm you
that's what every great Brewer of coffee
is looking for the Arabs knew it in the
early in the late fall
hundreds they called it Merc aha and so
my my journey took me right back to the
highlands of the Yemen outside the port
of Aden and the port of Maha keep that
word in mind important and it took me
back to this almost mythic character Ali
a man Omar a shoddily from the great
either loose family who are related to
the Prophet Muhammad himself and he was
a great mystic of that of that period a
glioma even a shoddily and either ooze
had students had disciples who were who
were with him and it is said that he
learned from his teacher Addabbo Hani of
this red cherry fruit that if you chewed
the fruit you'd become alive you'd
become literally electric we call
caffeine you'd litter and of course you
know when you have the coffee fruit it's
unfiltered that's all the caffeine it's
like fruit it's dry it tastes horrible
but you have it boo and so it was said
that a double Hani had been ill and he'd
gone to Ethiopia and on his way back he
had he had brought these coffee beans
with him we now know through vegetal
analysis that coffee arrived in Yemen
probably around 1,000 or 1,100 but
wasn't actually cultivated until a
little bit later coffee was not
cultivated in Ethiopia until after it
was cultivated in the Yemen so we often
say that coffee had its origins in
Ethiopia but it's found its sole in the
Yemen coffee found its sole in the Yemen
because in the menorah sadly spiritual
circle where they of course say their
canonical prayers but at night they'd be
swaying and singing and playing the
drums and they would gather together in
remembrance of God trying to achieve
mystical union with the divine what they
were doing was passing around the cup of
coffee throughout the night so initially
was chewing the cherries then they would
remove the husk called the g-shot
or the tisha and they would boil that
like a tea and the Arabs still do that
right hold on you boiled the you boiled
the fruit and it's very it's delicious
because you add cardamom and spices and
beautiful things into it
and eventually they started cooking the
beans on a plate or a hot plate almost
over the fire and then they would they
would grind it and they would literally
infuse it and what came out was probably
a very strong bitter brew but what was
amazing about it was that they would put
it into one cup and they would pass it
around and this will happen in the
ceremonies but of course religious
people can't keep everything to
themselves and soon in the port of Aden
in the port of MOCA in the surrounding
towns to where the Mystics lived people
started drinking coffee and they were
like what is this elixir what is this
beautiful beverage and so outside of the
mosques the Sufis would serve the
Mystics would serve and they realize man
coffee grows everywhere so people
started cultivating their own plants and
by the time we get to the late 1400s the
Yemen particularly in that region is a
coffee drinking is a coffee drinking
culture it's a coffee drinking culture
but something happens something that we
got to know about the Yemen and
something that's obscured by them I
think the news of the Yemen today is
that Yemen was the end of a great long
caravan route to Aden from all the way
from Damascus and Cairo and
Constantinople and Byzantium and the
Sassanid Persian Empire these was the
flow of goods in and out across this
amazing thing called the island of
Arabia Jazeera - Arab they were going
back and forth back and forth back and
forth and the Yemenis were hearty
traders so what did they start doing
they take the green beans with them and
they'd go on their journeys and that
brings us to pictures of the Yemen
itself the pictures are almost
unbelievable these are pictures taken in
the last two years some of you will not
know that the first skyscrapers in the
world were built in the Yemen the Yemeni
architects and the people particularly
from the valleys of HUD remote and
around it built buildings sometimes of
six seven eight ten stories which had
running sewage which transported water
and which were built on these incredible
outcroppings
this is one of the farms this is one of
the Citadel's a village which sits along
that one of the valleys where coffee has
grown today look at that
I mean stunning steppe architecture
steppe irrigation was in the Yemen from
at least the 1400s and look at how
hurtin that is that is what for me it's
almost like a visual shock to when I
think of the Yemen I read in the New
York Times or The Washington Post or I
see on CNN today this is where people
live and they continue to cultivate
coffee and these valleys these rift
valleys surrounded by mountain and
sometimes desert but lush valleys extend
for hundreds of miles and then we get to
1511 no story about the Middle East is
complete without a good foot walk
without a good religious edict keep that
in mind for your later studies of
Islamic in Middle Eastern history in
1511 the mum Luke which was a was a
dynasty which ruled from Cairo and it
was actually known as the slave dynasty
because these had been people who'd been
enslaved and had not only freed
themselves but had become the rulers of
the land the mamluk dynasty controlled
what is now known as Mecca where the
holiest shrine and site of Islam is the
Kaaba to which all Muslims who pray turn
in their direction of prayer in 1511 the
potentate the local ruler Mamluk ruler
of Mecca was walking along outside the
precincts of the holy mosque and he
started smelling something delicious and
then he saw a group of men sitting
together drinking this delicious thing
and he saw the fire and he could see the
popping of the of the beans and they
were imbibing and they were singing
songs and he's like what is going on and
so he went to his he went to his
advisers he says I've seen this in the
Holy Mosque what is this
and they said ah it's got it's got wha
this is the people from Yemen they drink
it all the time he says why haven't I
heard of this gawa higher bay was his
name it higher to be was an interesting
cat
because he wasn't a very good ruler
first terribly corrupt but not only that
he had another problem in town he had an
alcohol problem because in the holiest
of cities of Islam speakeasies and
taverns were going up from time to time
people were floating the sacred law and
therefore higher bay was under pressure
from the religious authorities shut down
the the taverns and the places of
alcohol and now this new thing comes
into being this thing called coffee well
long story short he could means a
Council of the scholars he brings two
Persian doctors who taste the coffee and
in order to ingratiate themselves to
hire they take the coffee and as it is
written in of the colleges series
history they swoon as if they have taken
some deep intoxicant like hashish or
opium they swoon and they say oh my god
I can't see clearly anymore I can't
stand up oh I've forgotten my prayers
and they collapse to the ground and all
the scholars said oh my God look at this
ban coffee and so immediately a
religious edict was written in the name
of God we ban coffee because it is an
intoxicant like alcohol like hummer like
wine and spirits and hired a thought he
was real clever
so he rolled it up gave it to his
emissaries and said take it to the
Sultan take it to the king
mum look King in Cairo and tell him I
have found an evil and I have Co
vanquished it well it took a while for
that to get across the desert it arrives
in Cairo and the last muscle Don because
he's about to be overthrown by the
Ottomans in 1517 he looks at it and
basically rips it up because little does
hire to bei no coffee has already
arrived in Cairo and is being drunk in
the Royal Palace so unhappy was the
Sultan with Haier Bay he said hi Bay
back to Cairo with you you're in big
trouble and those religious scholars who
signed the edict the head one bring him
back as well and those two doctors bring
them back as well now I have a bit of a
macabre story but Halloween so I'll tell
it I think God has a bit of a sense of
humor and I often say that that coffee
is God's beverage and no amount of human
interference
in it can stop it higher be returned to
Cairo and was literally drawn and
quartered for insubordination and
stupidity the scholar who had signed the
edict died a very terrible death it
overtook him and the two doctors the
Persian doctors on their way to Cairo
they were killed by highwayman Roberts
what does that tell you don't mess with
coffee by the time we we get to Cairo
coffee is the beverage and now think
about Cairo Cairo sir I want you to kind
of imagine Cairo for a moment today it's
a city of 15 million people by day 20
sorry 21 million people by day 15
million people by night but Cairo is the
heart of learning a place of gardens a
place of libraries and and and mosques
and seminaries and and research and
scholarship from all over the world and
in the back alleys of the great al-azhar
university created by the great Fatima
the Empire many centuries earlier the
students from the Yemen who are studying
at the al-azhar bring their coffee with
them and they bring their coffee and
they're brewing it and the other
students from are saying oh can we have
some and so these little coffee shacks
forum in Cairo but we also know that in
1530 the first cafe opens up in Damascus
and we know that before 1550 for there
are cafes in Aleppo in the great cities
of the east the the the crossing point
of Empires coffee is now being drunk as
a popular beverage it's not without
controversy in 1521 a scholar from the
al-azhar declares coffee a Haram or
impermissible again the it lasts about
two weeks because when the next shipment
from the Yemen comes all is solved and
in 1532 during the holy month of Ramadan
a very zealous police chief tries to ban
coffee
and it results in riots people riot
through the streets and say you can't
take our coffee away from us and by that
time the Ottomans have realized this
coffee thing it's a cash crop people
want this beverage I'm going to change
tack for just a moment then we're gonna
come back to the bulk of our story in
the Yemen the Ottoman Empire now
controls the coffee trade I want you to
think of this like controlling the sugar
trade or controlling the oil trade this
is now a massive cash crop all of the
coffee in the world virtually at this
point all the coffee in the world is
coming from the Yemen I'd only think
about that it's very going from the
Yemen everywhere else the colonial
powers have already started having a
look in and it is said that no live
coffee plant can leave the Yemen on
punishment of death so what happens is
that all the green beans when they're
picked are boiled to kill off any
possibility of them being planted that's
how seriously they took it but there was
one man a pious man from India known
popularly as Baba boudin they say and
Baba boudin was a mystic he'd gone to
the Yemen to study with the Mystics and
he was on his way back to India because
of course travel to India was not
uncommon and Baba boudin said I love
coffee I think I can break the law so it
is said that Bob Abu Dharr took seven
seeds some people said that they put it
in his luxurious beard probably much
bigger than mine some people say that he
tied it in a band around his chest what
we do know is that during the late 1500s
coffee begins to grow in the region of
Karnataka in South India where coffee
remains until today along the Malabar
Coast coffees first home outside of
Yemen is not Colombia or Brazil but is
actually India and India plays a very
important role in the story and the
history of coffee and here now we come
to the third act in our story
the third act if Ethiopia was coffees
origin and Yemen was where coffee
founded Seoul it was an ottoman
Constantinople that coffee became an art
form this I know you can't see it too
clearly this is an ottoman era miniature
and our expert in Islamic art my friend
Sultana Qasimi can give us more details
on this later this is a miniature
describing what an ottoman coffee house
would have looked like and if you look
closely you will see in one corner the
coffee being brewed in another corner of
the scholars sitting reading the
religious texts and and other musicians
in another people playing backgammon in
another people smoking the nerdy la the
hookah the shisha and all of them being
served coffee by who in the ottoman
culture of coffee a personality
developed call it the first barista the
first barista was known as what the
cavity Basha literally the Pasha the
master of coffee that this was the
person in and they were they ended up
being women cavity boxes and Mail cabeza
boxes and in fact in the in what is
known as the harem or the women's
quarters of the Ottoman Sultan there was
it's there was in that in those quarters
female cavity bosses who would serve the
mother of the Sultan and the wife of the
Sultan and the consorts of the Sultana
the cavity Basha
the barista became so important because
the barista was here all the
conversation in the cafes in 1554 to
Syrian merchants opened the first coffee
shop in Istanbul and after that we lose
count
thousands of cafes open and if you can
visit I want you to imagine they're
serving the best coffee in the world
the Yemeni coffee is the purest and best
coffee in the world to this day and
we'll talk about that right at the end
the quality of coffee I had one on
coffee entrepreneur and Istanbul tell me
about three years ago when I was working
on a documentary on coffee for the BBC
he said to me he said you know what the
funniest thing is he says we talk about
specialty coffee now he's
in the place that I am today if I was
here in 1620 in Ottoman Istanbul I'd be
drinking better coffee than this and
blew my mind and I'm like absolutely
it's coming from the Yemen it's organic
no pesticides it's it's the good stuff
that's coming and for the Ottomans it
became an obsession but this is where
the social revolution happens and
particular for our young students I want
it I want I want to keep this in mind we
grow up all of us grow up with places
that we gather we go to the shop we go
to the cafe we go to restaurant to go to
a club we go we go to places if you can
imagine in these cultures and societies
there are actually very few places where
people interact formally the mosque the
Marcus which is the souk where you spy
and sell the madrasa and then maybe the
tavern but it's kind of not allowed
there very few places there's no
restaurants per se until after the
coffeehouse the coffeehouse the ottoman
say is the divan of the home the place
of gathering in the home outside of the
home the coffeehouse is a social
revolution because we create a space
that's not about commerce per se that's
not about religion per se
that's not about learning per se it's a
place where you and I get together and
we just talk and maybe we exchange
information maybe we make business but
we talk and we gather and I don't know
who's gonna come through that door
because what was amazing about the
coffeehouse from it's very beginning was
that it was a place of many different
social classes later on the coffeehouse
becomes for rich and poor but during
most of the period of the coffeehouse
and it's one of the things that
surprised the European travelers the
priests and others who were doing
missionary work who are travelling to
old Byzantium going to the sacred sites
in Jerusalem what were they seeing they
would go into the coffee house it's a
it's a most unusual place with a rich
and poor gather together and they talk
and they play backgammon and they smoke
hookah and at night they tell stories to
each other
how did stories like the that the tales
of the Arabian Nights which were which
were
collection of folktales how did they get
disseminated in the coffee houses people
sat and listened to each other's stories
travelers came and regaled them with
details of worlds they did not know this
became the CNN the New York Times
this became the Twitter and the social
media of its day that's what makes the
coffeehouse so special and Ralph's hot
ox the great historian of coffee said
this would not have been possible
without Muslim culture and the culture
that developed out of Muslim
civilization because encoded in coffee
was a sense of service one of the
beautiful things you see when we travel
through the Middle East is a sense of
welcoming the traveler the caravanserai
offering something beautiful giving a
drink come you're our guest this is a
dub this good manner of welcoming guests
becomes enshrined in a place like the
coffeehouse and here we have the big
picture we start here in the Yemen
coffee goes to India and then as the
coffee travels through the Arab world
into Turkey but the colonial powers are
hot on the trail of coffee the Dutch are
the first to successfully steal the
coffee plant and they take it to where
they take it to Ceylon and then they
take it to Amsterdam where they try to
grow it in the Botanical Gardens and
that botanical plant is very important
to our history from Yemen coffee
eventually returns back to Ethiopia and
has begun to be cultivated a little bit
later but then there's other roots
there's several routes to India and the
Dutch take it to Ceylon present-day Sri
Lanka and coffee is grown in Sri Lanka
and then coffee starts making the big
journeys the Dutch take it to Java the
just take it to Java in the late 1600s
to the port of Batavia modern-day
Jakarta where they try first
unsuccessfully and then successfully to
plant coffee over here in Java in
modern-day Indonesia the
French steel a coffee plant and they
take it to the small little island right
there off the coast of Madagascar called
Reunion Island and Reunion Island to
this day has a special varietal which is
known as Borbon if you ever see Reunion
Island Berwyn buy a bag it's expensive
but it's delicious and from Reunion
Island now it starts into the African
colonies as the colonization movement
spreads from from the Netherlands it's
given as a gift to king louis xiv
in the early 1700s that plant which is
planted in the jardin des plantes on the
on the left bank of the city of paris a
shard of that is taken to Martinique by
an intrepid colonist and he plants it in
Martinique beginning the French growth
of coffee in the Caribbean but the
Caribbean sees Italian Jesuits bring
coffee
eventually the Portuguese get into the
coffee game
the Portuguese were very eager in fact
some say the Portuguese were the first
experienced coffee but the last to get
their hands on a plant and the
Portuguese now spread it the French now
spread it and now what else is going on
at this time students what other big
transatlantic trade is happening at this
very time triangular trade what's
happening who is being transported
triangular trade enslave people there is
a dark relationship between coffee and
enslavement as coffee becomes to grow
more popular in the cities of Europe and
initially it reaches places like Vienna
where of course there's trade with the
Ottoman Empire as there's this trade
with the Ottoman Empire but now as
coffee becomes a global commodity this
dark history begins and slave labor is
used in places like Haiti the island of
Hispaniola which makes up Haiti and the
present-day Dominican Republic and in
fact it is said that the Haitian
Revolution happens because enslaved
people revolt against the the wicked
difficult conditions that is placed on
them because of coffee production
because of coffee production and so what
you have all of a sudden
is coffee begins in the Yemen but is now
jumping around what does that mean to us
culturally and I'm going to finish on
these last three slides culturally
speaking when we get to 1600 coffees
being drunken in places like Venice
why because Venice has trade with the
Ottoman people's and in Venice people
are drinking and the Cardinals and the
bishops are seeing this and saying what
are you drinking this [ __ ] elixir
they say this Turkish brew this heathen
beverage
God gave us wine they declare because
wine is sweet but God gave the
[ __ ] the blackest most sutiya stay
a beverage because it comes from the
devil himself and so it was called The
Devil's cup and you'll read it in the in
the Catholic annotations so in 1600 when
the bishops realized they were losing
the battle against coffee they went to
the Pope Pope Clement the 8th and they
said Pope Clement you must declare
coffee the devil's cup and you must make
it impermissible for a good Christian to
drink it Clement was a smart cookie
Clement said well I can't declare
something illegal and unless I've tasted
it so bring me some coffee so coffee was
brought he liked it so much it is said
that he turned their request on said he
says the devil's drink is so delicious
we should cheat the devil and we shall
baptize coffee colonization the growth
of coffee
Pope Clement allowed for all that to
happen because he baptized him Clement
knew that coffee was the first one of
the first major global trading beverages
global trading commodities soon sugar
would come and salt was coming and
spices were coming and soon petroleum
would be found part of the global
economic system develops around coffee
in 1683 the city of Vienna has laid
siege for the last time by the Ottoman
army the Janissaries the Ottoman Corps
they got all the time in the world so
what do they bring with them every
battalion of the Ottoman army has its
own cavity Basha
they bring the barista with them he
carries all of the stuff of he cares all
the stuff and on the battlefield
soldiers are off fighting huh the coffee
is being brewed it is said in 1683 when
the Polish army routes in league with
the Hapsburgs routes the ottomans from
the gates of Vienna that there's bags
and bags of coffee that are left over
and it may be an apropos story the
double agent who engineered the coming
of the polls a Ukrainian by the name of
Franz coach it's key goes to the
Habsburg Emperor and said all I want is
the coffee on the field of battle and a
little place in the center of town it is
said that he establishes Blue Bottle
coffee company the first major car a
cafe and B and although there were some
from before and he becomes an incredibly
rich and wealthy man and finally my
friends we come a little bit closer to
home to London
if Ethiopians were coffee had its origin
if Yemen is where it found its soul if
in Istanbul Constantinople it became an
art form than indeed in London is where
coffee becomes an all-consuming culture
by the height of coffee there's a
coffeehouse for every hundred and forty
people in the City of London there is a
[ __ ] literally you had your own private
cafe almost and it's because of a man
named Pasquale rose a a Greek man who
served a British trader in Ottoman
Greece and when that trader was coming
back Pasquale rose they said let us
start a business dear sir he said what
business he says we have trade with the
Ottomans already we will bring the best
of their beans to London and let me set
up the shop you need to do nothing just
invest in it he said it's a deal in 1652
in st. Michael's alley you can see the
location today in the great city of
London in the heart of the of now
billions of dollars of financial
industry in the shadow of Lloyds of
London the great bank and insurance
business there's a little sign that says
here Pasquale rose a opened the first
coffeehouse and how what how what did he
do he dressed like a Turk the robes of
the Ottomans of
turban and he would go through the
streets and say come be served be served
the beverage of the East the virtuous
beverage some of you read it this
morning in your in your in your primary
sources coffee became so he became rich
but the Turks head became associate
whenever you see a Turks head drawn or
engraved into would you knew that was
where the coffee shop was this is just
literally I will tell you because I've
walked these streets myself this is no
more than two city blocks in the heart
of London just a little slice for you
there is a coffee there was a coffee
house called the Atheneum for poetry
there was a coffee house for politics
there was a coffee house for science
there's a coffee house for news Lloyd's
of London was a coffee house and became
a bank the first newspaper started in
coffee houses people would walk in to
coffee as they were known as penny
universities why it only cost a penny
and you paid on your way out
you didn't pay on your way in you sat
down in a coffee shop on your way out
the person at the door would say give me
your penny some coffee houses didn't
even charge only a penny they would say
you cannot enter the house until you
present a new couplet of poetry you
can't enter the coffeehouse until you
give us a piece of good news you don't
you can't enter until you tell us what's
down at the docks so someone will come
into the coffee shop and says oh I've
heard that claudia has just won the won
the Kings lottery oh we heard that three
hours ago go away bring us back
something and then you can enter the
coffeehouse the coffee houses became the
social libation Habermas called them in
his more recent work the great public
squares where people would meet penny
universities where the uneducated would
become educated where people would learn
to read where people would get news this
was the coffee this was the coffee house
of London this is where it became a
culture a powerful social political and
economic force where deals were struck
where colonies were divided it happened
in these coffee houses and yet coffee
brings us back beyond all of that and
this is we're just literally skimming
over the surface of the story because
the story is deep and fantastic and
wonderful and I could go on for hours
and you would throw coffee beans at me
but I do want to say this I want to say
that I think what elude me and why I say
London was the place where coffee found
its its greatest expression of culture
was because of the vitality of the
coffeehouse the place where you and I
didn't matter race religion especially
in the early days of the coffee house
later on coffee houses became more
bifurcated and the rise of tea and the
rise of alcohol and the decline of the
British Empire in particular in relation
to coffee meant that coffee became less
lucrative and that's why in Europe you
have a bigger coffee culture than you
have in Britain because in Britain tea
became the culture but in Europe up
until really the modern period coffee is
still very heavily traded the British
don't trade as much coffee
the Americans trade a lot of coffee
because coffee came to the United States
when with the founding of New Amsterdam
the very founding of this country in
those first send us first century and a
half coffee's already here it is said by
the time the city of New York is
incorporated and sold the New Amsterdam
is sold and the city of New York is
incorporated that the taverns used to
serve beer and coffee side by side
coffee becomes an incredibly important
libation but for me it's all about this
if there's something about the culture
of the Middle East to which I feel great
affinity and the culture of the broader
Muslim world the Muslim civilization I
feel affinity it's this picture
Palestine Jerusalem at the turn of the
10th century still the cavity Bosh's
brewing the coffee roasting the beans
grinding them and then presenting them
to the old men maybe coming out of the
mosque
maybe enjoying an evening but having the
coffee together in a group I love that
because that was my first experience of
coffee it was sitting with my parents it
was having free conversation it was
being out of the house it was the smells
the liveliness there's something
beautiful and powerful about that
seductive about that and this is a
picture today of my friend both are
essentially a great coffee entrepreneur
and this brings us back to the Yemen
over the years Yemeni coffee was in
strong decline a lot of it because of
mass production a lot of it because of
the growth of drugs like khat a lot of
it because large particularly Saudi
operations were buying coffee at the
lowest price over the last five years
most are a Yemeni American who grew up
in the worst neighborhoods in Brooklyn
and Oakland has gone back to his home
country the Yemen and has become a
coffee entrepreneur I'm happy to say
that from less than $1 a pound for the
last three years running
the coffee now produced by these farmers
and I'll tell you are really sad but but
beautiful story to finish these coffee
farmers now make anywhere from five to
six dollars a pound the coffee for the
last three years has been the
highest-rated coffee by the Specialty
Coffee Association of America ranking in
the 90 mark 96 97 98 isn't it
percentile of coffees that are grown and
at Blue Bottle coffee company in
Brooklyn one cup of these beans sells
for $16 $16 for a cup of coffee I know
it's shocking I had paid that much
however because I'm crazy and it's
delicious this is such a cool picture
and mostar's gonna be visiting us by the
way next term so I hope we'll get the
word out to you that he's gonna be here
these farmers have never tasted their
own coffee 100% of this of the stock is
sold to foreigners they work the coffee
their whole lives instead they chew khat
they chew are the slight narcotic which
also grows in their farms this is a
picture of the first time their coffee
has been brewed with a measure of
excellence they've tasted it and most
are told me the story said literally
they were crying they were saying that
our grandmothers produced this our
grandfathers produced this and we really
have never understood what a beautiful
thing we had with us again the power of
coffee to bring people together to give
to make it the common man's gold to make
it a feeling of luxury and nobility and
of course they say
that coffee is just it's they say it's
an excuse you know the Glee that comes
from coffee isn't really from the coffee
itself it's from the good company you
don't need to add sugar to your coffee
the company should be enough and so I
hope in this in this very quick but a
little bit long journey to the history
of coffee you've been inspired and I
hope something of it will stay will stay
with you and I know the students have
some awesome questions so I just want to
take a few of them because I want to
honor their amazing work that they did
over the course so thank you very much
first of all and we are gonna and I see
I'm gonna start over here can we could
Sarah is that okay okay ready
Lucas right so I'm Lucas and how did
India affect coffee with its ancient
culture I asked this because I was we
were looking at a painting and you saw
how the Arabians and the Muslim
influence had on coffee and just seeing
how ancient India is methods culture and
how large population is what did India
do it's such a good question then and I
I wish I knew more I know that coffee is
brewed in a particular way in India per
ticket in Tamil Nadu in the south and
coffee is much more popular than tea in
parts of South India well it is
interesting those two things I can I can
comment on one is that the coffeehouse
culture became very much part of the of
the social movement culture in India so
a lot of unions and a lot of social
movements would open coffee houses as
almost club houses for their members and
that really started happening during the
British period so so really during the
early 1900's late 1800s
you saw that so there must have been a
coffee culture already my friends who
are from Karnataka I have some friends
from the Malabar Coast from Kerala when
I've asked them about coffee
they say that coffee was very much part
of their lives growing up not only in
the cafes would they would serve it with
a lot of sugar but also it was brewed at
home a lot more and I think that's maybe
part of the Indian culture is that
there's this sense of the home and the
hearth where it's its brew but but thank
you for that question because you raised
it earlier and I'm
it's got me thinking now and and of
course you know I was speaking to my
friend who's of Armenian background he
was telling a beautiful story about the
way they they brew the coffee in Armenia
with the sand and and and that slow
beautiful brew that brings out the
flavor the thing is that coffee and
culture sort of mesh into each other you
know each culture takes on the beverage
and makes it its own in a certain way
which i think is really which is really
beautiful
awesome question man all right thank you
so I know that every single cash crop or
a majorly produced crop that like indigo
or coffee has always had a very violent
and sad history hmm and seeing all these
trade routes made around them in our
textbooks and stuff I've never like saw
myself personally I've never seen a
coffee trade routes through our text in
our textbooks so why aren't we taught
about yes my is my question exactly I
kind of feel like it's a good question
it's really missing I have I'm gonna
give an answer some people might not
like it but I'm gonna give it coffee is
deeply associated with Muslim
civilization and Arab civilization in
particular and I think our history books
are terribly Eurocentric and I think if
you're gonna trace the the history of
coffee back you have to go deep into the
relationship between Europe and this
thing that we call Muslim culture and
civilization the arabic-speaking world
and beyond and that is a relationship
unfortunately that is not covered well
in our in our textbooks I honestly
believe that and I'm sometimes shocked
even with Starbucks you know what they
used to give out this leaflet but the
history of coffee would all be about
called me the goat herder from Ethiopia
whose goats ate the coffee beans started
jumping up and down and that's how
coffee was discovered I'm like dude how
do we get from the goat herder to to you
know global training I mean there's a
whole story there so I think a lot of it
and I think you're good to ask the
question yeah I think those are the
kinds of historiographical
that we need to ask about what we're
learning so I sincerely appreciate that
we're gonna go
this group here and that saying that
we'll come back go ahead I'm gonna get
you on the mic so everybody can hear you
was coffee used for anything except like
was coffee used for like medicines or
anything yeah so there's there's an
interesting there's an interesting sort
of medical so we know that for example
coffee was identified as early as 1100 a
thousand to eleven hundred by some of
the but some of the the arab
practitioners of medicine and in their
books they talked about this plant which
they gave various names to and they said
it would give sprightliness and energy
to those who were down or depressed or
those who had lack of energy in their
body so this idea that that they didn't
call caffeine but that it was seen for
its medicinal value very very early
nowadays of course we accept them but
there's no value of coffee but also
there's all debates around whether
caffeine is good for you or not but
nowadays we often talk about caffeine as
being an essential ingredient and
painkillers because it helps the body
absorb much quickly so there's something
about caffeine that is that it's alive
and it's potent I am definitely of the
caffeine is awesome camp and I believe
that the tea Lobby is paying is paying
researchers to give us alternative
advice but that's take news so I I hope
I will fight I will fight the case of
coffees corner till till the end self
included go ahead can it be only tea
though can it be only tea I'll tell you
something interesting about Japan and
I'm glad you raised Japan because I
think I think one of the things we think
about is that well you know teas from
China Japan Korea there's that there's a
tea culture and of course there is in
recent times the Japanese have boom
owned the loss of their tea culture
after the Second World War coffee became
the most popular beverage because the
presence of Americans and American GIs
so a lot of old tea houses became coffee
houses today Japan is considered amongst
the finest
brewers of coffee in the world they've
turned coffee into an art form
when I went to Tokyo I literally spent
my days they're going coffee shop that's
all I did and I saw the entire city was
beautiful but I'd go to places where
honestly the baristas would be have like
have like you know braces on their arms
I was like dude what happened did you
fall you know I start pulling shots from
6:00 in the morning and I only give them
to customers at 11:00 it's a craft for
them and so I think you find that in the
East Coffee has become a real a real art
form about longevity
I would I would argue I would argue that
that that they live longer for other
reasons I'm sticking to it go go ahead
student questions your group over there
yes yes go for it please yeah here we go
this is towards you like what is one
thing that you find so satisfying about
coffee
and what about it makes your day just
beautiful coz I've noticed that you just
love it so much you know I I say there's
two things one is that you know when
when that morning cup I drew it myself
and I have that first taste it's just
there's so many flavors there's fruit
and berries and there's all kinds of
things that begin to happen but there's
something in my body that immediately
when I have it I go oh and I allow the
flavor to overwhelm me and I think
that's because my wife and I kind of
joked that there was one day that we
actually had a God shot this beautiful
shot of espresso and it was in London it
was one of our favorite cafes which was
run by actually a Greek couple who were
young and moved from Athens and lived in
Athens in Australia actually and they
lived in London and they did their
coffee was called the taste of bitter
love I love that name taste of bitter
love so my wife and I before we had our
son used to go there every Sunday and we
were sitting outside on a Sunday autumn
day we had me I already had one cup of
coffee with them
and the the barista came over aces guys
I've just made something for you it's a
it's a new queen I've got in I don't
know how it's gonna be but I think
you'll really like it he gave it to us
and dumpling my wife was not an espresso
drinker at all she was a brewed coffee
drinker and that took a while as well
because she never grew up with coffee or
tea strange but she is from Bangladesh
so I don't know how that works into it
both of us had the coffee and I remember
we were silent because it was this
amazing flavor it was like it rolled
over my tongue and it never achieved
bitterness it was like an intense
sweetness that took over my mouth
and and and we both looked at each other
and we're like what just happened it was
like we were transported and I think
that's thing about flavor I mean flavor
is so powerful you know we I you know I
think about my grandfather who was
paralyzed for most of the second half of
his life and he lived in that the
southern Punjab but there were days that
I know that a certain food would be
cooked right and and he would smell it
and he just smile and all this memory
would flow back into him he would say oh
your grandmother used to make this or or
I remember my mother making this I mean
smells have history to them don't they
they remind us and one of the pieces of
poetry that two of you read was the poem
by the Palestinian poet Mahmoud Darwish
who in 1983 wrote about the coffee that
his mother brewed
you can't not read that and not weep at
the end because he remembering his mom
and he's remembering the love and it's
not coffee anymore it's the house and
the home and memory and and in fact in
India to your question there's a there's
a the coffeehouses of old India from the
colonial period are nowadays called
palaces of memory because they're all
these places were a lot of history is
preserved on the walls and so it's it's
quite magical so I would say that those
are the kind of magical things for me
that have we'll take one more question
so do you believe that coffee was the
first quarter between social and
economical boundaries yeah I mean I
would argue and I think based on the
evidence coffee really is the sort of
beverage or food
which broke that boundary between public
and private that created in cultures
where there wasn't a tradition of
restaurants or cafes this space and out
of that everything else grows if you can
imagine how disruptive it is to break
out of the nexus of the of the mass the
markers the madrasah the religious
institution the economic institution and
the knowledge institution and to have
space out of that for this course this
course is happening of course what's
happening in your home right there's a
there's a custom of the Diwan the houses
and the East are designed for it there's
a room that is for the guests everyone
comes in Utah you-you-you-you discourse
you concur you share but now to take
that outside of the house and for that
to be and also would trade comes
cultures coming together cultures come
together the cultures of Europe mix in
with the cultures of the Muslim world
and vice versa they influence each other
they have an effect on each other when
the Moroccan ambassador in 1604 arrived
in Elizabethan London and he's walking
around with his fine robe people looking
at it so where did he come from the next
year a fellow is published you know and
the coffee houses are growing because
it's an Arab drink there's all these
interesting connections and I think
that's in a way we're living in a world
I feel often that we're living in a
world with those social interactions
those fuzzy edges would not pay enough
attention to them you know I think we
live in a time of silos and I think
coffee with every sip helps us free that
and remember when you have that
Tanzanian coffee in the Ethiopian coffee
think about the farmer think about the
women and men who picked that coffee
it's hard work you gotta pick it you
kind of dry it you got a hull it you got
it you got to make it good and and try
as much as you can to buy from places
that do direct trade at the minimum fair
trade but direct trade so that we know
the stories I love part of them I love
our coffee the story in every cop I know
that I'm what I'm drinking I'm drinking
someone's sweat and their blood and
their tears and their family it's all
gone into that cup and that's like with
anything all the things that we eat and
produce someone had to produce her
someone struggled for it someone's may
be in poverty because of it
so as part of this awareness that I
think each and every one of us
personally can develop around around the
foods that we that we eat and the things
that we imbibe thank you so much for
being so patient your questions were
awesome I hope you can gather them
because I'd love to have a I'd love to
have a copy other which would be rich
it'd be awesome
[Applause]
[Music]